diese schuhe sind aus stein anstelle von
leder ist an vielen stellen elastischer
schiefer verarbeitet produziert hat sie
das nachhaltige luxuslabel netto aus
münchen
sebastian thies leitet die
innovationsfreudige sneaker schmiede
seine familie stellt seit sechs
generationen vorher doch stein ist auch
für ihn ein völlig neues material
hunderte millionen jahre alt also
wirklich naturprodukt jedes paar schuhe
ist ein unikat
rein technisch gesehen gibt es jetzt
keinen vorteil zu leder weil die schulen
schon teilweise etwas fragil
also jetzt in sibirien bei minus 40 grad
wird das schon etwas schwieriger aber so
im alltag absolut alltagstauglich und
tragbar doch wie wird der stein so
flexibel dass er für einen schub genutzt
werden kann
ausgangsmaterial sind riesige blöcke
marmor oder schiefer mit einer
speziellen methode werden daraus
millimeter dünne platten
der clou ein elastisches trägermaterial
das mit dem stein verklebt wird eine
erfindung des berliner unternehmens
troxler erreicht man eigentlich niemand
in ganz ganz dünn gestaltet und wir sind
im bereich unter einem millimeter und
verbinden diesen stein mit was stabilem
sozusagen haben wir verwenden dort
unterschiedliche trägermaterialien wie
in fiberglas oder ein baumwoll fließt
was sozusagen den steinen die stabilität
gibt dass die einzelnen steinpartikeln
auch bei biegungen sozusagen
zusammengehalten
durch ein geheimes verfahren bei dem der
stein im wechsel hitze und kälte
ausgesetzt wird bekommt er seine
endgültige flexibilität und kann sogar
vernäht werden neben den schuhen gibt es
auch gürtel sonnenbrillen oder taschen
aus stein
doch der einsatz des materials in der
mode hat auch seine grenzen
das ist schwierig stein jetzt als zb t
shirt oder jacke oder sowas zu tragen
also auch dort haben wir schon
experimente gemacht aber
atmungsaktivität und beweglichkeit ist
eben nicht so gegeben wie bei anderen
materialien was wird weiterhin
kostspielig und aufwändig bleiben und
daher eher eine nische als den
massenmarkt bedienen eine nische hat
sich auch sebastian thiers gesucht für
seine schuhe experimentiert er immer
wieder mit ausgefallenen materialien wie
leder aus zunderschwamm einem baum pilz
oder mit stroh von wiesen aus bayern und
österreich aber auch kaffee
milch
holz oder leder haben schon als material
für seine sneaker gedient den ersten
kompostierbaren schuhe entwickelt und
deshalb sind wir bei diesem thema
naturmaterialien eigentlich schon immer
im thema gewesen und heutzutage passiert
halt sehr viel weil natürlich das
bewusstsein der leute größer wird und
deshalb gibt es auch mehr innovation in
den bereich recht gummisohlen pflanzlich
gegerbtes leder innen sohn aus kork auch
die unauffälligeren teile seiner schuhe
sind größtenteils natürlich für uns ist
nachhaltigkeit erstens eine
selbstverständlichkeit also nicht
unbedingt dieses mode thema wie es oft
in den medien im moment propagiert wird
es ist einfach für uns ein hochwertiges
oder auch luxusprodukt ist keins wenn es
nicht nachhaltig ist mit seinen schuhen
aus stein geht sebastian thies seinen
innovativen weg konsequent weiter